the two countries brokered a seven-day
humanitarian truce between the Army and
the paramilitary rapid support forces it
came into effect on Monday Riyadh and
Washington say preparations are underway
for humanitarian relief operations in a
joint statement though they've accused
the warring factions of ignoring pledges
not to seek military Advantage before
the ceasefire began the United Nations
says millions of Sudanese who've been
trapped by the fighting since mid-april
are in desperate need of assistance well
let's speak to our correspondent hibber
Morgan she joins us live from omderman
that's Northwest of Khartoum how about
you're one of the last foreign
correspondents left on the ground there
I believe you drove through the capital
yesterday can you talk us through what
you saw
thank you
uh yesterday afternoon we drove to the
northern part of the capital through the
city of bahri uh in hartum and we saw a
lot of checkpoints set up by the rapid
support forces and one thing that was
very noticeable is the number of
civilians that we were able to see on
the streets very few people remaining
behind in the city of bahri many of the
houses that we drove past were clocked
clearly you could see the keypads and
you can see the locks on the doors to
show that the residents of these homes
have left the city of Bahrain due to the
ongoing violence we were also able to
see a lot of bullet marks in many of the
buildings that lie along the main roads
in the city of bahri as well as signs of
homes being destroyed by artillery or
being burned as a result of the fighting
between the rapid support forces and the
Sudanese Army now Bahari in hartum North
is one of the cities where intense
fighting between the rapid support
forces and the Sudanese Army has been
taking place days many of us of its
residents have fled from Bahari leaving
very few behind those who we spoke to
say that they're they're saying to
either guard their properties out of
fear of being robbed and looted or
because they don't have the financial
capability to leave to neighboring
states and be able to support themselves
there we also saw a few dead bodies
along the main roads in the city of
bahri and it's clear that it's from the
latest fighting that took place about
four or five days ago between the rsf
and the Sudanese Army many people there
say that they do want the ceasefire to
hold for it to be able to come in but so
that they can get a sense of normalcy in
their lives but when you look at bahri
and when we drove through Bahrain it's
clearly not the same uh place that we
know it before the conflict started
exactly 40 days ago
can you give us a sense of how this
later ceasefire is actually going and is
any Aid getting through
well yesterday while we were in Khartoum
North we were able to hear sporadic
gunfire and it's not clear if it was the
rsf or the army or if if it was just
warning shots being fired by the rsf as
it was at a distance from where we were
in the northern part of the capital but
in umdurman we were also able to hear uh
the sounds of gunfire late into the
night and it's not clear again where the
attack is coming from but we do know
that there was fighting between the
rapid support forces and the Sudanese
Army in the central part of the capital
Khartoum and in the early hours of
Tuesday Morning in the city of alubade
when the rsf tried to attack the
military Garrison in the city in North
Korea and the Army responded using Heavy
Artillery fighter jets were also flying
overhead on Tuesday and we were able to
hear the sound of it early this morning
as well all of this of course is a
violation of the ceasefire that was
signed in the Saudi city of Jeddah and
because of the ongoing violence Aid
organizations many of them have have not
been able to deliver Aid to the capital
heartum they say that there's been
logistical challenges that there's an
issue of security for their staff and
for the aid to be delivered and the
medic group Doctors Without Borders say
that their offices in Fortune has been
occupied by the rapid support forces and
that several of their offices has been
robbed in different parts of the country
hampering their operations so lots of
challenges for Aid organizations to be
able to deliver Aid to the millions who
are still behind trapped in the fighting
here in the capital Khartoum and in
other parts of Sudan as well
Morgan they're our correspondent on the
ground in onderman thanks so much Evan
stay safe